[Music]
foreign
Titans seen in the monster verse first
we will describe each of them briefly
and then go on to their comparison so
let's get to it
firstly the Maya squid within the 2017
movie gong Skull Island the Maya squid
also known as gigantis levipus emerges
as a colossal cephalopod subtitle
combining octopus and squid trades it
bows of a Rotan octopus-like head with
enormous eyes and eight long arms
adorned with suction cups it's big like
Jaws typically concealed within the
bubble's head possesses a unique ability
to spin rapidly creating whirlpools to
ensnare and sub unsuspecting prey these
formidable Ambush Predators call the
Waters of Skull Island Home exhibiting a
survival focused nature despite their
massive size their behavior appears to
be driven solely by the hunt and
findings suggest that they may be
relatives of the giant Pacific octopus
evolving with distinctive mutations due
to the Island's unique ecology when
threatened the myasquits deploy dymatic
tactics releasing heated black ink to
obscure themselves from attackers while
simultaneously boiling or hurting the
attackers alive with the high
temperature ink
so the second one the Kraken so in the
waters near Skull Island a colossal
aquatic Titan known as the Kraken was
seen in the Animated Series a bizarre
amalgamation of various creatures like a
chimera its upper body resembles a pale
blue octopus boasting six tentacles
adorned with suction cups transitioning
into more fish-like form that culminates
in an immense tail fin it also possesses
Crimson prehensile tentacles as well
which are smaller and thinner and they
emerge beneath its neck it also has two
massive tutorous pincers nearest
midsection with a colossal bulbous head
on top with a set of glowing eyes it
also has antenna coated in blue fuzz as
well as a fearsome black beak brimming
with sharp teeth this monstrous Titan
was fiercely territorial attacking any
vessel that dared to approach Skull
Island dragging entire human Crews into
the abyss with its small tentacles it
was Sinister and evil in a way it had a
bit of rivalry with Kong which brewed
when it fatally wounded a young woman in
that was cared for by gong though its
immense size the kraken's vulnerability
to Kong's fossil blows became its
undoing
the third one titanus nakika so in the
kotm novelization titanus nakika is
described as colossal octopus or
squid-like Titan with a protective shell
around its massive brain in Godzilla
Dominion its imposing figure is unveiled
showcasing a streamlined body with eight
thick octopus like tentacles adorned
with hundreds of suckers an arrowhead
shaped tips with bright blue eyes also
an insectile face nakika also spots two
imposing black fin like wings throughout
history there have been sailor Tales of
a monster cephalopod that developed
entire ships earning the ominous
classification of Destroyer by Monarch
Monarch's technology eventually locates
an invisible doorman nakika called
around the remains of a long-lost
nuclear submarine in the Indian Ocean
before the events of kotm and then she
later escaped the containment facility
that was built around her to heed the
call of Ghidorah she was later trapped
by Titan traffickers between kotm and
versus skull and was freed by Godzilla
during the events of Godzilla Dominion
and lastly Titanic Cellar socilla is a
colossal armor cephalopod Tyrant which
made his debut in Godzilla King of the
Monsters the movie initially Cilla
featured a brownish Hue with six lengthy
segmented legs each ending in pointed
claws adorned with spikes on top her
pleated mantle house 10 tentacles and a
pair of orange eyes while a distinctive
inward curving shell resembling that of
an ammonite was on its stop however in
Godzilla Dominion Sila underwent some
changes trading her swirling
ammonite-like shell for a slope downward
curved one and instead had white
tendrils instead of tentacles her unique
role in the ecosystem involves
Scavenging as she consumes dead Titans
and converts their bodies of Flesh into
deadly bacteria that are capable of
contaminating water also she can also
shed her shell and use sunken Battleship
parts or rocky surfaces as makeshift
armor until a new one is formed to
protect her invertebrate tissue her
ability to release amounts of liquid
nitrogen also AIDS in preserving the
Antarctic eyes thus stabilizing sea
levels
so these four Titans each bring their
own unique blend of design size and
powers to the Titan ecosystem the Maya
squid or gigantis levipers presents
itself as a colossal cephalopod with a
round head gigantic eyes and eight
suction cup adorned arms its ability to
spin its big like Jaws into whirlpools
makes it a formidable Ambush predator in
the Skull Island Waters with a length of
around 110 feet or 33 plus meters
meanwhile the Kraken found near Skull
Island shows combines elements of
octopus and fish with its pale blue
upper body six suction cup covered
tentacles and a massive bulbous head
with massive chaitin pincers like those
seed in crabs starting between 200 and
250 feet tall it is indeed one of the
biggest monsters to be seen in Skull
Island until Kong reach adulthood it is
also bigger than a Maya's quid but
smaller than the other two rail Titans
and then Titanic Cellar is different as
it is heavily armored than the rest
spotting six segmented legs ending in
Spike Claws and a unique inward curving
shell resembling an ammonite as I've
just said earlier so in Godzilla
Dominion it adopts a sloped shell and
cilla's Scavenging role involves
converting dead tires into a soup of
deadly microbes which means that out of
the Fall it alone is a scavenger it is
also the second biggest of the
cephalopod monsters measuring 341 feet
tall on the other hand the Italian snake
the biggest here is 898 feet long and
classified as a destroyed Titan
resembling a massive octopus or a squid
with bright blue eyes a set of imposing
black ring-like fins and eight tentacles
it is different from Cilla in that it is
more like an octopus in shape different
from the Maya squid due to its immense
size in coloration and different from
the Kraken in that it has no sturdy legs
or Pincers
so regarding size alone the smallest
here is the Maya squid with a 110 feet
or 33 meter long body and then after
that comes the Kraken which is twice the
size and height alone stunning 200 to
250 feet or 61 to 76.2 meters tall these
two are Kong's enemies and their
sightings are associated with the ape
titan okay then we have Cilla or
titanicila which was 341 feet or 104
meters in height and lastly there is the
biggest nakika which is 898 feet or 274
meters long and these two are associated
with Godzilla regarding their bodies the
Maya squid and nakika are soft-bodied
monsters while the Kraken Ancilla both
have sturdy legs and degrees of
tightness armor regarding their
intelligence the Mayas quit alone is
animalistic while the other three have
varying magnitudes of intelligence with
nakika theorized to be as smart or even
smarter than calm himself and as for
special powers they all have their own
and their single most notable ones
respectively are camouflage and
invisibility for nakika Vortex suction
for the my squid liquid nitrogen
emission for Cilla and electrical
discharges for the Kraken and that's
about all we have for now
so those are the four squid Titans of
the most of us and their differences so
I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
on new videos here on this channel take
care fam